difficult choice to make between king d6
and rook takes e6 but in our studio we
have a young man a young grandmaster who
is absolutely on fire five and a half
out of six in the last rounds he is with
christian carrillo celebrating his
victory thank you alejandro yes we are
ended with a very happy uh victor and
new co-leader of the big group abimanu
misra abimani first of all big
congratulations five and a half out of
six in the last six rounds
how did you do that
yeah i just i mean after losing my my
second game round against ali miranda i
just
i just thought yeah like it's one game
nothing and i've i've been preparing for
this tournament for like over two months
and all the preparation like okay one
game can go bad in the tournament but i
felt that it will it will eventually
show you are playing uh this round
against the leader of the event uh the
invincible man in this event you are
also playing with the black pieces
how did you approach this game did you
see it as a must-win situation
yeah i kind of saw it as a mushroom
situation if i was competing for first
as such but the thing is like when
you're black you cannot
against a very strong opponent if they
want to make a draw of the opening you
cannot you cannot like just you can't
avoid them you can't stop them you if
you do that you'll just lose the game
right there so i just i just was i was
thinking i'll just play whatever lines i
usually play and just play a game if he
plays on and we get a game good and he
did and he did play on and you guys got
a game and actually let's take a look at
that game yeah tell us a little bit of
the critical moments where did you feel
you started uh really getting that
advantage
obviously you're up a pawn but the
position remains very complex yeah i
actually when i was discussing when i
was discussing it with him a few minutes
upstairs ago uh so he said that this was
all his preparation and he's after
knight g4 engine said to play knight
takes e4 for whatever reason no no it
was not knight g4 it was knight c before
so he forgot his preparation
and castle you have knight to c6 right
yes yes
yeah that's a big difference so now
you're forced to exchange one pair of
knights and that's a big difference
ah
because i can put some more pressure
with the root coming to c1 rook fc one
yeah that was the main reason why i
didn't take e4 because i felt if i if i
took on e4 then he has like rook fc one
with like one
one his uh it's a queen side attack as
one move faster
yep
so
he castle then it felt like you started
to take over
maybe around here maybe like yeah c5
this is uh this is still a complete draw
after bishop c5 rook c5 and yeah he
missed the rook of five move
and i think bishop 3 is a mistake here
actually why didn't he go e3
yeah e3 i think there's some some crazy
lines like rook takes f2 but i'm not i'm
not entirely sure if they work like this
should be seven queen takes c queen
takes e3 bishop takes a8
oh my goodness and now like rook did
it's rook d it's a threat and if you go
like age six ninety four and you not
yeah ninety four and he he can just give
up his queen
at least right
king is just very safe on h1 so now you
just play h6 even this doesn't work huh
yeah i don't
maybe yeah an ig-14 h3
yeah it just doesn't work the king is
fine on
on g2 yeah that's a funny line
rick takes f2 i guess he got scared yeah
but after e3 i mean there were some
i think maybe uh black is fine here but
there's like some lines which you should
avoid like bishop takes g2 is like the
most natural move if rook case have two
doesn't work but i think here white has
rook takes a6 oh yeah that's a nice move
and now there's like two lines rook
takes a6 b takes a6 queen c6
we can see how queen b3 rook d that's
made and now there's like rook d8 98
queen b8
and i think it was king of fade a7
and yeah if you go look at five queen
before you lose what about bishop f3
which f3 bishop f3 uh you have queen to
b4 okay bishop f3 i promote yeah oh you
promote and that's the checkmate
checkmate
yeah yeah
yeah that's the lost actually i don't
see a defense and instead of uh if you
don't play this if you go back a few
moves there was some issue with if you
play
queen b7 instead of rook takes a6
there was rook takes a hit queen they
say queen to a4 just make sure you don't
play queen a3 because queen x83 queen f8
but yeah after queen a4 you lose your
fees back there's nothing you can do
right because the threat is to trade and
broke the aid and yeah there's actually
nothing you can do about it it's kind of
sad
yeah so i was planning to play something
else but
it's
weight should be fine i guess
but a big mistake with bishop f3 and you
took full advantage of it immediately
yeah
or in 95 yeah 95 and
instead of 95 i think rook takes f3
what's another move but
this also leads to some crazy variations
like rook takes up three knight d5 i
think
knight d5 uh-huh knight d5 uh queen
takes f2 check rook takes f2 rook takes
b3
and now white has knight c7
and maybe black is somehow winning here
but i couldn't see it like rook city has
ba6 and i have two a7 so you have to go
to k7 okay seven you have rook d2
and bsx
then he just stays like that yeah
yeah i mean it's harder harder to say
that you're gonna win with this opponent
on
a6 always being a problem yeah
well a lot of calculation in this game
was necessary it takes 95 94. and now i
had this nice knife 3 queen b7 idea but
maybe queen bc like for some reason
engine doesn't like queen b7 i don't
worry about it at this point it says and
pretty much everything's winning yeah
it's already a complete yeah knight d4
is also like completely winning you just
take b5 you just didn't want to be as
fancy as you were but queen b7 is there
definitely a good move don't worry about
it yeah i just wanted to like finish
this as quickly as possible as such
because queen like 94 1935 will be
winning in the long run but again such a
resourceful opponent i didn't want to
take such risks and if you lose the a6
pawn then it's going to be a very
difficult conversion right yes
well certainly a bunch of games one
there in a row for you we just got
stopped with a draw uh
one yesterday ago yesterday
did you expect to come in and wipe out
so many opponents in a row
i didn't actually expect this but i was
i was just trying and as as i said
before i was i've been preparing for
this tournament for a very long time and
i felt very confident in my preparation
and now everything is working out
perfectly well you seem like a happy man
and certainly we are happy to see you
make progress of course all eyes on abi
manu the youngest grandmaster in the
history of the game and one final
question for you abby money tomorrow you
have a big clash against christopher eu
a player that probably is going to be
one of your main rivals for
years to come how will you approach that
game
i'll approach it the same way i approach
every game just play just try and just
play whatever i can do best
whatever and whatever goes on after that
is that's not in my control absolutely
that's a very healthy attitude to have
good luck tomorrow and we're looking
forward to see you tomorrow thank you
yeah bright and early